small businesses have accounted for all
the job growth in the U.S since the
covid-19 pandemic began big companies
have actually cut jobs over the past two
years alphabet the parent company of
Google is cutting 12 000 jobs Microsoft
plans to cut 10 000 employees about five
percent of its Workforce this could
become a serious problem if the economy
slows down this year as small businesses
are typically the first and worst hit in
downturns I'm going to tell you what's
been happening in the labor market why
2023 could be a tough year for small
businesses and why that could spell
trouble for the U.S economy as a whole
let's get into it since February 2020
small businesses companies with less
than 250 employees have added more than
3.6 million net jobs meaning they've
hired over 3.6 million more people than
have been laid off or quit large
businesses those with 250 employees or
more have cut 800 000 jobs in that time
not only that small businesses account
for about 80 percent of the 10.5 million
job openings in the U.S as of November
as Jeffrey's Chief Economist annetta
markowska puts it small businesses are
literally holding up the labor market
she says this was largely the result of
government stimulus programs that
boosted small businesses revenue and
spurred them to jumpstart hiring the SBA
that's the U.S small business
administration is offering low interest
rate Federal disaster loans for
businesses suffering as a result of the
coronavirus but things could go south in
2023 the Federal Reserve World Bank and
IMF are all predicting the U.S economy
will slow this year and many large
financial institutions are predicting a
recession
small businesses are more exposed to a
slower economy because they typically
have less resources to fall back on if
consumers aren't buying new products
right now they're facing an environment
where workers demanding higher wages the
cost to borrow money is increasing and
banks are becoming stricter about
lending big companies have lots of cash
stashed on their balance sheets but as
financial markets turned last year many
pulled back on hiring and some started
announcing layoffs
small businesses have carried the torch
but data from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics show hiring slowed in the
last few months of the year
while large firms can increase their
cash buffers by borrowing money through
Capital markets selling bonds and
issuing new shares of stock small
companies typically rely on bank loans
and the immediate cash in their sales
and banks are tightening their lending
standards and making fewer loans if
consumers pull back as well we could see
U.S jobs growth slow to a standstill and
even turn negative fewer Americans with
jobs combined with less spending higher
borrowing costs and Banks pulling back
on Lending is a recipe for recession so
clearly small businesses will play a big
role in the health of the US economy
this year you might want to think like
rapper 21 Savage who said on his recent
track with nods forget the jewelry I'd
rather buy land and invest successfully
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]